[Music]
[Applause]
i can barely even say that without
crying
[Music]
it's 6 p.m and i just now got to camp so
the plan while i'm here is i want to go
check out arches national park for
sunrise tomorrow um because the park has
a reservation system and i don't have
one so the only way for me to get in is
if i go before 6am or after i think 5pm
so i'm aiming for sunrise and then i
want to go do canyonlands for sunset i'm
just super excited to be back here i
love canyonlands national park it was
actually the first national park that i
ever went to alone i was living in
denver working at abercrombie at one of
the stores there waiting to get my visa
to go over to italy and i was just so
burnt out on being in a shopping mall it
was around black friday thanksgiving and
i was just like over it so
one day after work i got in my rental
car and i drove
out to the mountains and just kept going
when i arrived it was 11 p.m or
something like that i drove in and just
no one was out there because it was so
late
and i just remember the stars and the
milky way and
just seeing it stretch from one end of
the sky to the other and i just
i'd never seen anything like it my whole
life i would even say it was probably
the beginning of the end
once i was exposed to that
feeling of being outdoors
i realized that retail was not my jam
and being in a shopping mall is it just
wasn't what i wanted to do anymore so
it would be a while before i got out but
yeah i'm so excited to be back here and
hopefully share these places with you
i'm sure many of you have already been
here before and if you have then
you know why it's always worth coming
back just to give you an idea of how
many people are out here like this is
way down at the end of the road so busy
out here so no one can actually park
around me there's this tree and a
fireplace and then it's like a little
plateau
um and i do have a neighbor over there
and over there and
turns out
this spot has a bathroom
also can i just take a moment
to talk about how much
i really hate hearing generators out in
nature
[Music]
do you remember
[Music]
so
[Music]
both are meant to fall apart
[Music]
take me
free
take me
[Music]
[Music]
stone
[Music]
[Music]
your heart is
take me
don't let go
waking up
[Music]
oh i can't really get down far enough to
be in frame um so my camera card is
completely full uh this is the last
little bit i have left here and which is
crazy it's like 256 gigs i don't know
how i use all that but anyway i need to
import everything and change out my
battery because it's almost dead because
right now is like the perfect time to be
shooting the benefit of having your
office with you everywhere you go i can
just import everything and freshen up my
battery and keep going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
just got to the moab mailing center
picked up my package and i asked them
when i was in there if i could
bring this back in for recycling so
pro tip
i am on my last errand of the day
hopefully i just got groceries and gas
and now i am at the shower
[Music]
i don't think you guys can even hear me
over this
[Music]
[Music]
you know those moments where you know
without a doubt that you're exactly
where you're supposed to be
this was one of those moments for
me despite the lightning and thunder and
sporadic hail i drove to the island in
the sky mesa and canyonlands national
park
i was the only one there
alone
on an island in the sky
i didn't really mind
darkness has its own kind of beauty
but then
something wild happened
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
canyonlands
is a really special place that i came to
after my grandfather died
i can barely even say that without
crying
but anyway i came here and i thought
about him a lot
and coming back here and having that
experience was like
that was definitely my grandpa
[Music]
today was a really good day
okay
i guess i gotta go find a place to sleep
you